[Musik]
an der chesapeake bay in maryland zwei
stunden entfernt von washington teilen
sich die meinungen eigentlich immer
schon haarscharf nur mit 0 5 prozent
vorsprung hat joe biden die wahl im
landkreis gewonnen
hier bei den menschen in saint michaels
muss er mit seiner politik punkten
die bevölkerung ist politisch tief
gespalten
ich bin eigentlich enttäuscht er hat
versprechen gemacht die ihr nicht hält
hatte versprochen alle zusammen zu
bringen
das tut er nicht dass er so viel in 100
tagen geschafft hat ist ein wunder
es wird nicht mehr an jeder ecke
gestritten
das ist nett man kann jetzt wieder mehr
miteinander reden als vor 150 tagen der
umgangston ist ziviler geworden meint
auch scott bergner der ehemalige
republikanische senator und
gouverneurskandidat in pennsylvania hat
einiges an beiden und vize-präsidentin
harris auszusetzen dazu kommen wir noch
aber erstmal lobte er sie leiden ist
entschlossen feld blitzschnell
entscheidungen
ich habe heute morgen ein interview mit
camilla harris bei cnn gesehen
die fällen wirklich entscheidungen und
das habe ich in der geschwindigkeit noch
nie gesehen in washington
manchmal lässt sich anstiften ablesen
was ein entschlossener präsident
erreichen kann diese hängen in der
johnson bibliothek lyndon johnson
unterschrieb mit ihnen die great society
gesetze die amerika sozial und
wirtschaftlich ein stück gerechter
machten mit johnson wird joe biden gern
verglichen
auch er will eine umwälzung und beide
waren vorher senatoren die wissen wie
man dinge voran bringt in washington
sein corona hilfspaket mit fast 2
billionen dollar verabschiedet im
kongress ohne eine republikanische
stimme und seine impfstrategie finden
knapp 70 prozent der amerikaner gut
seine gesamt zustimmungsrate 53 prozent
hält die weiße haus experten marc coma
für erstaunlich seine stärke ist das was
er hinter den kulissen tun kann mit
hilfe der beziehungen die er über die
jahre gepflegt hat deshalb findet vieles
was er tut vertraulich stadt nicht
öffentlich die nation soll aber sehen
dass er sich bemüht mit den
republikanern ins gespräch zu kommen
über seine großen reformpläne doch wenn
notwendig machte den alleingang beiden
folgte einem peniblen terminplan jede
kleinigkeit ist getaktet für etwas ganz
großes ein neues amerika im dreisprung
das corona paket ein
infrastrukturprogramm mit kampf gegen
den klimawandel nun noch der plan für
amerikanische familien mit kinder geld
teils kostenloser kinderbetreuung und
fachhochschul- bildung gesamtpreis
schild 6 billionen dollar bezahlt vor
allem aus steuererhöhungen für die
reichen
beiden war für das geld zum fenster raus
meint scott wagner
es gebe drängendere probleme zum
beispiel die illegale einwanderung
die kümmern sich gar nicht dumm was an
der südgrenze passiert die
vize-präsidentin soll den mist aufräumen
aber bisher nicht nur und auch der
präsident nicht eine schlimme lage
es ist die größte schwachstelle der
neuen regierung allein im märz kamen 170
tausend illegale einwanderer darunter
viele unbegleitete kinder die aufnahme
lager sind überfüllt
zisch prozent der amerikaner sehen
beides unentschlossenes einwanderungs
management kritik camilla harris soll
das problem lösen sie spricht direkt mit
den präsidenten von guatemala mexiko und
honduras im juni wird sie auch dorthin
reisen
die vize präsidentin ist die engste
beraterin von jo baier auch bei seiner
entscheidung für den abzug aus
afghanistan manche warnen vor den
risiken
aber die so signalisiert beiden mit
seinem besuch auf dem arlington friedhof
rechtfertige nicht mehr das leben von
us-soldaten zu riskieren
er wendet sich globaleren problemen zu
beim klimagipfel bringt ja auch
widersacher an den tisch mit denen
amerika und seine verbündeten auch
schnell in militärische konflikte
schlittern könnte jetzt hier seinen hut
zu der chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz wieviel beiden in
100 tagen schon erreicht habe auch im
umgang mit china
es wird eine der ganz großen
herausforderungen nicht nur im jahre
2021 solle in den nächsten 3-5
vielleicht zehn und mehr jahren seien
die europäisch-amerikanische abstimmung
über china hoffentlich nicht eine
kritische streitige auseinandersetzung
sondern hoffentlich finden wir
hinreichend felder der überlappung und
felder gemeinsame gemeinsame interesse
dass die liberale demokratie stärker ist
als der autoritarismus dass sie noch
liefern kann für die menschen freiheit
sicherheit und wohlstand das wollen ja
müssen diese beiden beweisen
es wird dann gehen wenn er sagen kann
ich habe tatsächlich eine politik
erfolgreich für den amerikanischen
mittelstand für den normalbürger führen
können und das wird er umso leichter
nachweisen können
je stärker er zeigen kann dass amerika
nicht mehr die gesamte last der
verteidigung der sicherheitspolitischen
lasten europas tragen muss auch hier in
st michaels tief gespalten zwischen
demokraten und republikanern muss beiden
die mitte der gesellschaft gewinnen
nicht jeden republikaner wird er
überzeugen können aber einige
er macht sich ans werk
wie ein arbeiter und umgibt sich mit
hochkompetenten fähigen und anständigen
menschen keiko diesem punkt jeder hat
sein ruder und rudert und macht seine
arbeit gangster amerikas kurs scheint
ruhiger mit dem neuen mann am steuer
doch stürme können jederzeit entstehen
das weiß man an der chesapeake bay